in normal times you wouldn't be able to
see this
it's the wreck of a wartime boat that
sank over 70 years ago in a river in
italy called paw
this piece of history is usually buried
under water
but these are not normal times
devastator
italy's longest river is drying up
[Music]
fish are dying farmers are reducing
irrigation and nearby towns are
rationing water
it's the worst drought in 70 years so
why is it happening and what can be done
to stop it
you might have never heard of this river
but you're probably familiar with the
lambrusco wine basami kodi modena or
prosciutto diparma
they all come from a region nourished by
the pond
that's why it's called the poor valley
this is also one of the most
industrialized densely populated and
intensively farmed parts of europe
but the region is now lacking the same
fundamental resource that made it
flourish
[Music]
is the general manager at ambi a
syndicate of association that take care
of rivers and canals in italy a pretty
tough job right now
aquifers that hold groundwater are
depleted
the southern knobs already have no snow
left
many lakes around the river have reached
historic lows
and because summer is the driest season
the worst is yet to come
everyone in the region is affected
starting with farmers because much of
italy's production depends on irrigation
christianoffin is the president of an
association that promotes farmers rights
and the farmer himself
[Music]
and it's not just food production
hydropower is big in italy forty percent
of the renewable energy produced in the
country comes from hydropower
but with no water power plants will be
brought to a hold at a time when energy
prices have already jumped because of
the war in ukraine
that's not the only way people will be
affected
drinking water is also already being
rationed
so why is this happening
well experts point at both long and
short-term vectors
the most important recent factors are
sudden low snowfall and high
temperatures
and on top of that temperatures are on
average two degrees higher
left the river without its summer water
reserves
but there are also long-term factors
which are related to climate change in
italy it doesn't rain like it used to
in italian
but how it falls has changed
dramatically
[Music]
rivers and canals cannot absorb all that
rain there's the risk of devastating
floods
a staggering 89
of rain is lost this way only the
remaining 11 is retained fizz suggests
that something can be done to improve
the situation
in the short term there are only
unpleasant solutions
higher draining from alpine lakes less
water for hydroelectric plants and
rationing of water in the upstream
regions
[Music]
but in the long term even though
temperatures are likely to keep rising
the situation can be improved and
there's already a planet
a bunch of new lakes to collect at least
some of the 89 of rain that is now
pumped into the sea
[Music]
the problem will be in the medium term
until the infrastructure catches up with
climate change
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]